oh oui merci arnaud effectivement on
parle de l'actualité politique avec
cécile winter meilleur pour le ps
stéphanie modde pour europe ecologie les
verts alain suguenot pour les
républicains et juni redouble pour le
front national alors quand on parle
quand on pense actualité politique on
pense déjà à 2010 est finalement
aujourd'hui il y a le conseil national
de les républicains à la porte maillot
me semble-t-il à paris c'est jusqu'à
demain je vois tout à l'heure c'est pour
fixer une ligne 10 nicolas sarkozy est
ce que c'est un peu hypocrite parce
qu'on sait que des rivalités y aura
peut-être plusieurs lignes donc ça dans
la république il ya déjà plus
aujourd'hui
on l'a encore vu contre de riez pas
longtemps simplement ferait pas que ces
primaires cube tellement les débats de
personnes jusqu'au 20 novembre et
j'espère simplement qu'on a
effectivement parlé de projets parce que
les françaises et les français lors
l'inquiétude première c'est pas de
savoir qui sera celui qui via les
primaires c'est vraiment de projet
différentes recettes
c'est ça mon inquiétude si à des projets
différents émettront comprends c'est
pour qui le même projet c'est
difficilement compréhensible on fera que
je serai en tous les cas moi 47 unités y
compris de la fédération pour faire que
l'on puisse aboutir un débat serein ce
qui compte c'est après ce qu'il faut
c'est que tout le monde soit bien sûr
comme un seul homme une seule femme dire
c'est lui qui sera le gagnant des
primaires sur un projet commun je crois
que c'est ça qui est important c'est ce
qui ce qui nous incombe aujourd'hui par
les agriculteurs tout à l'heure c'est
important d'en parler quand même si on a
un vrai projet aujourd'hui il faut vous
le dire mais en tous les cas il faudra
impérativement qu'on puisse répondre
présent aux inquiétudes mais c'est pas
une once de ménage dans le domaine
économique ou si on a des inquiétudes
majeures dans le domaine diplomatique
si avoir un projet international je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
attend françois fillon a pris un peu les
devants mais je veux dire
il faudra bien évidemment qu'on puisse
les uns ou les autres données c'est un
nicolas sarkozy là dessus a
ti métros et tramways ont dix jours
avance puisque c'est vrai que on l'a vu
encore avec son livre qui apporte déjà
au delà du mea culpa
déjà certaines pistes donc on va voir
par fidélité et d'amitié
on s'est connu à une période plus
difficile aujourd'hui par contre je
voudrais rester suffisamment d'autres
pour que justement on évite la
planification d'autres partis politiques
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut être là
dessus 47 unités mais je penche sur des
cas que nationale ça sera pas la réponse
c'est la messe nécessaire je crois il y
aura un président ou une présidente du
conseil national
il n'empêche que c'est pas si nouvelle
que ça va se passer c'est bien sûr au
niveau des programmes pour répondre
présent aux inquiétudes des français
bref est ce qu'ils les fossés primerica
on a vu que jean luc mélenchon lancé sa
candidature il a il l'a fait cette
semaine est ce que du coup une primaire
est encore possible vu le contexte y
serons c'est directement au minimum deux
candidats à gauche
déjà je vais faire je vais apporter une
précision c'est que je pense que les
français pour le moment c'est pas du
tout leurs préoccupations ne nous
trompons pas nous aimer sa rupture
savalli n'en débat pas d'aller justement
moi je pense qu'on est dans un
quinquennat
on est à trois ans et demi il nous reste
un an et demi de travail
on va pas pendant un an et demi sur un
quinquennat de cinq ans se focaliser sur
la question des primaires on a trop de
travail à faire à l'assemblée et sur les
territoires
donc moi c'est ma première interrogation
faisons attention nous nous sommes au
gouvernement nous sommes pas dans
l'opposition et nous devons faire
continuer notre travail nous avons
beaucoup de choses encore à faire bien
évidemment les gens nous attendent là
dessus or c'est sur les primaires bien
évidemment une primaire élargie
de toute la gauche et des écologistes
serait une dimension tout à fait
intéressant même avec un président
sortant
mais ce qu'on constate là c'est que
chacun veut l'union derrière lui donc
laissons un peu de temps à l'est sont un
peu de temps au gouvernement actuel pour
avancer pour peut-être réussir ce qu'ils
souhaitaient c'est-à-dire infléchir la
courbe du chômage et travailler à la
tente des français vraiment parce que
c'est ça qu'ils attendent de nous nous
le gouvernement il a qu'une chose à
faire c'est travailler et être efficace
et répondre aux questions
la primaire elle viendra en son temps et
j'aurais accepté à ce moment là
l'occasion de vous parler d'emploi
l'insee a annoncé hier qu'il y avait
pour la première fois depuis 2011 à
nouveau des créations d'emplois c'est un
petit signe qui vous rend optimiste moi
je vous laisse une bâtisseuse de nature
donc je ne suis je ne ne suis pas dans
le déclinisme et dans le discours
pessimiste je considère que nous avons
une responsabilité on a un gouvernement
de gauche
il doit faire sa politique de gauche
jusqu'au bout on lien avec les
écologistes parce que je pense que c'est
absolument essentiel dans la rénovation
politique - je poursuis et puis la prime
et à abyane viendra le moment venu mais
c'est pas la question qu'attendent de
nous les français c'est pas cette
réponse là cette question qu'ils
attendent de nous ils attendent de nous
une réponse aux problèmes de
l'agriculture c'est vrai comme vous avez
bien fait de le relever au problème de
l'emploi et aux problèmes des services
publics dans les territoires parce que
ça aussi c'est majeur de qu'il se rend
très optimiste sur les plages de repos à
pour ce club c'était un résultat bien
ancrée des emplois tous les ans on le
sait bien simplement leur pénétration
dépasse les coupures d'eau détruit ses
seins pour le fait julien houle la
question de la prévert ne se pose pas au
front national j'imagine donc d'une
candidate naturel et incontesté fait pas
forcément l'unanimité
bien sûr elle fait l'unanimité au front
national vous irez plus largement elle
fait l'unanimité auprès d'une majorité
de nos compatriotes
donc ça c'est ça le plus important nos
compatriotes qui sont comme des gouttes
et de gérer de ce système politiciens
des primaires qui disent beau finalement
considérez s'appelle démocratique
democratic on sait très bien que la
majorité des électeurs de ces primaires
sont des adhérents politique voilà que
sont les militants de nicolas sarkozy
qui vont allez certainement valider sa
candidature pour l'élection
présidentielle donc il évoquera si vous
recevez un marion maréchal-le pen
reyniès donc jeudi dans l'yonne c'est
pour faire quoi c'est pour lancer la
campagne pour avoir des adhésions c'est
pour voir leur ordre de bataille
c'est donc l'une au premier rendez-vous
patriotes donc le jeudi 18 février à
saint valérien
donc ce sont des grandes réunions
publiques nous allons organiser donc
tout au long de l'année 2016 pour
rassembler très largement donc tous les
patriotes de l'yonne qui ne soit au
fonds national ou pas d'ailleurs des
déçus de la droite il y en a beaucoup
dans le département pour leur montrer
que le front national est la seule
source d'espoir dans ce département et
au niveau national alors on voit déjà
que le front national est en ordre de
bataille
justement la seule force des sports
c'est certainement pas le front national
c'est certainement pas depuis tout à
l'heure monsieur ne cesse de nous parler
de déclin de peur d'angoissé la réalité
que n'ont pas la note c'est ce que vous
mettez en avant semble et nié tout
langue ne nions pas non non pas les
difficultés mais quand vous mettez les
migrants qui viennent de syrie qui
viennent de pays en guerre où est
impossible pour eux de rester quand on
sait qu on en accueille effectivement
très peu en france
je suis pour qu'on les accueille mieux
qu'on les mette dans plusieurs
départements dans le fictivement c'est
une très bonne idée de ne pas les
accueillir tous sommet au même endroit
de travailler avec l'insertion de voir
fait que peuvent rester en france de
construire vraiment quelque chose quand
on voit ce qui se passe à grande synthe
n'est absolument pas satisfaisant donc
il faut vraiment travailler sur cet
aspect-là avec dignité avec humanité et
solidarité pour solidaires va pas
reparler d'eux il a aussi comme suis
allé là aussi est ce qui profite cela
profite aux autres
stéphanie est donc pour en revenir à
notre sujet d'ordre de bataille lorsque
je ne souhaiterais pas surtout pas c'est
un second tour en 2017 avec le front
national qui arriverait effectivement
deux ne part avec la famille le pen
d'ailleurs c'est quand même dingue il
vient
on arrive effectivement de voilà de vous
arriver dans des moments effectivement
entendu vous vous excusez moi
l'expression mais vous faites votre
beurre sur ses mouvements avec de
tension quand ça va bien on voit bien
que du coup ils disparaissaient de
l'échiquier politique quasiment donc là
nous qu'il nous faut absolument c'est
effectivement un vrai projet de gauche
le projet de gauche actuellement c'est
pas mêlant chant pour moi mais c'est pas
la politique j'en suis désolé j'en suis
bien consciente que je ne me bats pas
contre mon propre camp mais ce n'est pas
la politique menée actuellement par le
gouvernement hollande valls je le dis
donc nous avons un véritable travail de
construction qu'effectivement avant
d'être présenté aux français doit être
présenté en intérieur c'est un travail
effectivement de partenariat deux
parties de théma d'arte construction 10
des visiteurs à la dynamique
non pour moi mais lancions d'attenté
mélenchon s'éloigne d'eux mêmes ils
semblent emmanuelle cosse était entrée
au gouvernement
mais ben et pas justement quand je parle
de reconstruction c'est aussi là la
survie
effectivement c'est la survie de la
gauche c'est la survie de la gauche en
tant que tel est-ce qu'on a des projets
communs est ce qu'on a envie de la
région fait pas la survie de la france
seul problème de ou le projet si parce
que la france sur vite monsieur elle vit
même elle vit elle peut vivre encore
mieux où nous en sommes d'accord ne me
parlez pas de service de la plus
intéressée non vraiment je dis juste
chez polycom alternatif de gauche on
parle peu on peut parler l'agriculture
effectivement on peut parler du domaine
de l' empêche d un bug ok tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'ils savent faire
effectivement on a enfin rompre avec les
cinq millions 6 millions de chômeurs va
pas se battre sur des chiffres quand on
en est à ce niveau là qu'est ce qui fait
effectivement qu'on arrête de détruire
des emplois
qu'est ce qui fait que le cic pourquoi
ça ne fonctionne pas pourquoi ce crédit
impôt ne fonctionne pas qu'est-ce qui
fait écho aux entreprises pour ne pas
embaucher ses salars évasion fiscale
aussi voyez on sera jean est pour ça qu
il faut aussi des gens il faut aussi
faudra effectivement moi je suis pour
alors là les primaires de la gauche bien
évidemment avec le ps sinon ça n'a pas
de sens donc ses heures voilà après est
ce que c'est moi je veux dire le
gouvernement peut travailler quels
qu'ils soient qui travaille ça n'empêche
pas un travail de fond est aussi est ce
qui est primordial pour moi ce qui
deviendra nécessaire dans ce pays pour
qu'on sorte de cette logique de
bipartisme de tripartisme c'est surtout
le sait la proportionnelle correspondant
enfin en france avoir un vrai système de
proportionnelle
le national non parce que oui mais ça
peut être aussi vous voyez bien
qu'actuellement l'absence de
proportionnelle
quelque chose qu'ils font davantage sur
la norme emv actuellement noir aux
pattes proportionnelle nous avons un
front national très fort donc vous
n'êtes pas contradictoire en plus voyez
au niveau national je vous explique pas
le qu'elle sera effectivement le ça
serait pas mal
le profil de la france n'a pas forcé la
quatrième république pouvait pas
demander à quelqu'un qui est issu du
gaullisme de revenir entre guillemets à
ses errances ont déjà suffisamment de
problèmes sur macge ou des crises
politiques aux crises économiques
le monde c'est pas dire vous ne changez
pas quand même pas mon flanc de
gouvernement c'est lé remaniement mais
vous ne changez pas la couleur politique
tous les trois mois au crac les
françaises et les français aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout ce qu'ils attendent
effectivement j'ai l'impression qu'on
est aussi bien au niveau des écologistes
du front national dans un système
aujourd'hui on pense déjà à conquérir
des postes ou à gagner les élections
avant même de penser comment rétablir
france ont pas les agriculteurs le vrai
problème c'est le parisianisme ambiant
qui fait que les textes et je veux bien
dire au 10 mai où quelques fois qu'il
fait de la droite ou la gauche
le texte aujourd'hui ne s'applique pas
du tout sur nos territoires il ya des
territoires en france le monde rural
souffre il n'y a pas que les
agriculteurs
je crois qu'on le voit bien quand on est
élu de terrain et s'était dit tout à
l'heure on s'aperçoit en tous les cas
que les vraies problématiques
y compris d'ailleurs les idées des
écologistes sont quasiment inapplicable
au quotidien le monde agricole en
souffrent tous les jours s'apercevant
crée un décalage complet sur veut vivre
à nouveau y compris sur le territoire on
est ici en côte d'or je crois qu'il faut
véritablement que le chant le langage
change mais c'est certainement pas les
institutions et modifiées entre
guillemets la vème république qui va
paraître de faire que les françaises et
les français vous reprend d'espoir dans
ceux qui les gouvernent elle modèle de
l'agriculture attend actuellement est ce
que c'est un modèle qui est prônée par
les écologistes sont à 5 ans l'objet sur
l'agriculture s'est excusé moi quand
même s'est déchargée au niveau européen
clearwell à moi je veux bien qu'on parle
de parisianisme il faut pas non plus
effectivement monter les gens les uns
contre les autres
ça fait penser à l'extrême qu'est ce qui
va faire en sorte la perception de
françois hollande qui aujourd'hui au
fond du trou si vous me permettez
l'expression libre des sondages
qu'est ce qui fait que ça va peut
changer 17la les résultats on attend les
résultats on a mis en place des
dispositifs il faut il faut il faut
maintenant que les résultats soient là
et il faut que la confiance revienne
mais c'est pas par des discours
pessimiste que la confiance reviendra
donc moi je pense qu'on a une
responsabilité entière pour porter
ensemble la france du xxième siècle et
on doit y arriver et on verra s'il ya
des résultats merci à tous en tout cas
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
la semaine prochaine la vraie vie il
s'intéressera au débat sur le régime des
allocations chômage mais tout de suite
c'est le 12/13 qui se poursuit avec
l'actualité nationale et internationale
travel après midi à tous
on